- I'm just imagining a big bowl
of scrambled eggs with bourbon in it.
("Jingle Bells")
- I've seen eggnog in movies,
but I've never seen it in real life.
- I think it's something
that you drink at Christmas
when you wanna get drunk and
forget about your family.
- All I know is that it's drunk
during the festive season,
so Christmas and the
weeks leading up to it.
- I can't tell if it's good or not
because when you see it in movies,
they either love it or
they really hate it.
- We don't really get a
white Christmas in Australia,
so this is probably the closest
thing that we're gonna get.
- I didn't think it was gonna be warm.
- I can smell the rum.
- It kinda smells like a dirty eggcup
has been left in the
dishwasher for two weeks.
- [Voiceover] It actually
looks like dishwater too.
- It sort of smells like
somebody's thrown up Christmas pudding.
- 'Tis the season to be drunk, my friend.
- Mmm.
(cups clanking)
- Mmm, that's quite something. (laughs)
- [Woman] That's good.
- [Man] Yeah.
- It's kinda like a glass
of milk with rum in it.
- It kinda burns going down,
so I can see why it's a
good winter Christmas drink.
- I can already feel it, actually.
It's warming me up and making
me feel a little bit happy.
- That tastes like someone spiked custard.
- It has surprised me.
I can't really taste the egg in it.
I was really worried it'd be really eggy.
- It's tricky because Christmas
falls in summer in Australia
and it does get really hot.
So, I can't see us drinking
something like this warm.
- I think maybe we
should try eggnog on ice.
- Mmm, that would be good.
That would be good for our Christmas.
- [Both] Thumbs up, for sure, yeah.
- Bottoms up.
- Yeah, I could get around it.
Maybe a Christmas in July thing.
- Americans know how to do Christmas.
They absolutely embrace it and--
- [Woman] They invented it.
- [Man] Exactly, and eggnog?
Just another tick on the list.
- Eggnog sounds like an insult
that you'd call someone,
like, "You're such an eggnog."
Yeah, "Oi, your indicator,
you (bleep) eggnog."
- [Woman] Exactly.
- [Man] Yeah.